we use cast-iron skillets all the time
in the tasty kitchen for a million
different reasons they're virtually
indestructible they last forever and
unlike a lot of things you're gonna have
in your kitchen they actually tend to
get better aged people are often a
little bit intimidated by cast-iron
thinking it's you know very hard to deal
with or hard to clean it's actually
really easy you just have to know what
you're looking for so seasoning is a
process you want to go through even if
it's new or you have an old cast iron
that was passed down to you often when
you have a new cast iron and there's
been any water that's left on they're
really susceptible to rust we're gonna
help you figure out how to prevent that
from happening and how to clean that off
so we're gonna start by getting some
steel wool whether it's new or has a
bunch of rust on it we're just gonna
scrub it down with steel wool with a
mild dish soap and just get it down to
its kind of base layer the way that cast
irons are made it's all kind of
one-piece and you can't just season the
part that you cook with you want to
season the entire thing while we're here
we're just gonna keep scrubbing along
all of the sides on the back of it turn
it over get the handle once you're happy
you got a raw standard gunk off there
you can go give it a rinse under hot
water and either use one of those mount
abrasive scouring pads or the tough side
of a sponge you just do another little
quick go around making sure you got
every milk and cranny a good rule to
remember whenever you're dealing with
cast iron is water will make it rust we
always want to get it as dry as possible
before we store or move on to the next
step so because of that we're going to
dry it off with a towel and then you're
gonna put it onto your stove and turn it
on and let all of that excess water any
extra moisture boil off once you're
happy your skillet is bone-dry
we're gonna take it off the heat and
start our seasoning process with a thin
layer of oil the new standard is that
flaxseed oil is the best oil for the job
it actually dries the hardest and
creates the best nonstick longest
lasting seasoning the only downfall is
it is pretty
offensive and if you don't want to spend
that much money or frankly just don't
have it in your pantry canola oil will
work just fine a little background on
your skillet the surface is actually
porous which just means there's kind of
small holes or pores even that we kind
of want to fill up to make a nice smooth
cooking surface so once we have this
thin layer of oil all over the skillet
we're actually gonna do our best to wipe
it all off there's enough oil that has
soaked into those open pores so take the
clean side of your paper towel and rub
off as much of the oil as you can one of
the biggest problems people have is they
don't wipe off enough oil and they have
too thick of the layer and then it comes
out of the oven very sticky still and
not giving them the result that they
want so you're gonna put your cast iron
and your oven on the highest temperature
to go between 450 and 500 degrees so
this process is gonna take about an hour
the reason why we need our oven so high
is we actually want to take the oil pass
it smoking point so that the oil
actually starts to break down and bond
with the cast iron so if you ever taken
out your skillet and it's still kind of
brown and sticky it's probably because
your oven wasn't hot enough so after an
hour you can turn off your oven let it
cool in there the result is a hard
glassy layer that we're looking for that
helps make our cast iron nonstick so
intro to cooking with cast iron you
actually really do have to preheat it it
doesn't necessarily heat evenly but it
keeps the heat really well so just take
your time heat it on a low to medium
heat this may take five to ten minutes
because cast iron is such a great
conductor of heat if you actually just
carefully hover your hand over the
bottom of the skillet you can feel when
the pans ready to go a lot of people are
confused you know they did all the
seasoning and their food is sticking to
the pan usually that's because they're
putting cold food in a cold cast iron
pan one reason to get a cast iron
skillet really is to sear things like
meat so another thing that people are
maybe confused about when they're
cooking with the cast iron is they tend
to want to just move the food around a
lot and actually what we're trying to do
here is build up a nice caramelized
crust so when you put any meat in your
hot skillet just leave it let it cook
and when you see
kind of brown crust forming on the
outside that's when you know it's ready
to flip so if you're trying to lift up
your steak and it just will not give
it's probably bleep it's not ready yet
the meat will self release when that
crust is formed why we love using cast
iron skillet to tasty to is because we
can start something on the stove and
finish it in the oven so you often hear
that you can't cook acidic foods and in
cast-iron skillets however if you have a
good layer seasoning on there that's
totally fine you don't want to do a ton
of no big tomato sauce or a bunch of
wine or vinegar but a little bits not
really gonna kill your seasoning don't
be afraid to roast things like tomatoes
in your cast-iron skillet the great
thing about being able to cook with
something on the stovetop and finish it
in the oven if you just have a lot more
control you can get a nice layer of
carmelization
from a high heat on the stove and then
finish something cooking in the oven on
a much gentler radiant heat so when
you're cleaning your cast iron you want
to hit a sweet spot if it's cooled down
too much the food will adhere and really
stick to the pan if it's too hot and you
put it in there cold water you can risk
it cracking so you want to wash the pan
pretty soon after you use it the most
gentle way to clean your skillet is with
hot water and salt and a nonmetal
scouring pad or the rough side of your
sponge the salt works is an abrasive and
helps to scrub off any food that's on
there without damaging the seasoning at
all once you're happy that your paint is
clean give it another towel dry and then
let it completely dry off either on the
stove or in a warm oven just to make
sure there's no lingering moisture and
that's gonna protect it from rusting in
the future so lastly we're gonna put a
protective layer of oil in the skillet
before we store it carefully with the
paper towel rub that all along the
inside turn off the heat until the oil
smoking then turn it off and look
stove the reason why we want to take it
after the smoking point it's so that the
oil doesn't turn Branson cast iron
skillets may seem like a lot of work but
it's followed these simple rules of
seasoning and cleaning and these pans
will last your lifetime
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]